موقع استراتيجي للروس وهدف استراتيجي
للاوكرانيين ليست المره الاولى ويبدو انها
لن تكون الاخيره في هذه الحرب هجوم عنيف
على شبه جزيره القرم جنوبيه اوكرانيا تتهم
موسكو القوات الاوكرانيه بضرب مدينه
سيفاستبول في الجزيره يقتل جندي روسي
وتسقط انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه خمسه
صواريخ اوكرانيه وفق روايه موسكو تتوقف
الحركه على جسر القرم في الجهه الاخرى من
الجزيره التي تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ 2014
لكن في سباستوبول غربا يتضرر مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي وفق الروايه الرسميه
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه والهدف من الهجوم
الاوكراني على ما يبدو اسطول البحر الاسود
في الجيش الروسي هو وحده فرعيه ضخمه في
البحريه الروسيه نطاق عملياته تمتد من
البحر الاسود الى البحر الابيض المتوسط
سفن الاسطول في عده موانئ على البحر
الاسود وبحر ازوف توكل الى الاسطول مهمه
تامين حدود روسيا الجنوبيه ويضم اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي غواصات وسفنا قادره
على العمل في البحار البعيده والقريبه
وطائرات حامله للصواريخ وطائرات مخصصه
لمكافحه الغواصات ومقاتلات بالاضافه الى
وحدات قوه خفر السواحل الاستهداف
الاوكراني الواضح للقرب يعيد الى الاذهان
اهميتها للروس من خلالها يشنون الهجوم على
المناطق الجنوبيه برا ومنها تنطلق الهجمات
الجويه على العمق الاوكراني لذلك يراها
الاوكرانيون هدفا مهما للغايه في المنظور
العسكري خلال حرب وفي المنظور السياسي
بالتاكيد على انها ارض اوكرانيه لا يمكن
التنازل عنها بالتقادم والمنظور السياسي
هذا هو الذي تتحرك فيه كييف بحثا عن دعم
عسكريا غربي واشنطن يبحث
مع الكونجرس ومسؤوليه اداره بايدن
السياسيين والعسكريين دعما يقلب موازين
الحرب تلك حرب لا يبدو ان استهداف القرم
المتواصل سينها لكنه قد يحقق للاوكرانيين
ما يبحثون عنه من اضعاف القدرات العسكريه
الروسيه في الجبهه الجنوبيه بعد اكثر من
600 يوم من القتال